la dernière campagne. Alors,
est-ce vraiment le cas? Olivier
Bachand à vérifier.
- En 2019, les libéraux de
Justin Trudeau ont promis ceci:
- On va baisser les factures
de cellulaire de 25 %
d'ici deux ans.
- Aujourd'hui, Jagmeet Singh
l'accuse de ne pas avoir tenu
son engagement.
JAGMEET SINGH, chef,
Nouveau Parti démocratique
- Il a brisé ses promesses.
Après deux années de
cette promesse, encore,
les frais sont très hauts.
- Est-ce que les libéraux
ont vraiment rompu leur promesse
de réduire de 25 % la facture
de téléphonie cellulaire
des Canadiens?
♪ ♪ ♪
Non, ils sont plutôt sur
la bonne voie de la remplir.
Selon Statistique Canada,
le prix des services
de téléphonie cellulaire
a baissé en moyenne de 24 %
au pays depuis la réélection
des libéraux en octobre 2019.
Sous la menace d'imposer
une réglementation,
le gouvernement Trudeau
a lancé un ultimatum
aux trois géants
des télécommunications,
Bell, Rogers et Telus.
On leur a laissé deux ans
pour réduire le coût de
certains forfaits cellulaires.
Selon la dernière étude
commandée par le ministère
de l'Innovation, ceux qui ont
des forfaits de 2 gigaoctets
de données et moins ont vu
leur facture baisser de 21 $
de 2019 à 2020. Une baisse
similiare a été observée pour
les forfaits de 5 gigaoctets.
Bref, plusieurs indicateurs
montrent que les libéraux sont
près d'atteindre leur cible.
Par contre, les Canadiens
continuent d'être parmi
ceux qui payent le plus cher
au monde pour leurs services
de téléphonie cellulaire.
Les prix des forfaits
de 2 à 5 gigaoctets sont,
en moyenne, 2 fois plus élevés
qu'au Royaume-Uni et 4 fois
plus élevés qu'en Australie.